what's up New York City does it be here
the LA of the East Coast say such a
grand old city I Love New York because
it's a better City than LA what Terra's
want to do damage they come to a real
city where they know they'll be heard
what are you even hit in LA with an
airplane you know you got a land the
Hollywood sign you're gonna land the
rough people over here with with your
wheel if you trying to kill people in LA
to spaced out for a good terrorist
attack of 9/11 story you have a bunch of
immigrants come from another country and
make it big in the big city hitting down
the park with their one big shot really
anything they really did it very
effective well I like how we have extra
security on 9/11 as if it's the date
that's a problem and not our foreign
policy
you ever notice how these servants you
know really kooky 11 days in a September
surely defy about this date prowl up
there they're in heat that's a bonus I
like that idea of a terrorist looking to
the calendar like oh I love it it's
coming up we should do something nice
for America you know being in New York
you know the subway nice idea reading a
book in Arabic which kind of freaked me
out but then I thought hold the corner
of the page you put a book away I was
like I think God he's got future plans
not a racist got to get to the end
I hate homeless people begging for
change on the subway so I usually switch
cars that way I can take note of them
over and over again to the face no again
sir I haven't followed you again why we
sometimes also just two cars in front of
them to do their whole life before they
get there
we had this before this guy's the thing
there's all those people they're pretty
awful I don't like for people I think
they're disgusting and I want to get rid
of every single poor person in the world
by giving them a lot of money does time
is that way you want to keep that bar
that the evil is another culture that's
what people do when they're starving
they're hungry they fear that they'll
stop probably so much they're doing it's
got to have speed these pores people all
their life you know who's taking all my
money it's not that favorite so that's
funny than me they've got my money what
about the people with the money no maybe
they take your money because they have
it now the people that and when they
were gonna pretty good a man patriotic
people I don't think everyone is
patriotic is stupid okay
but I do think everyone is stupid it's
gonna be a little patriotic because they
got nothing good to a lot of your life
you're gonna be like well at least I'm
here this is the best here I think
redneck
you know they're [ __ ] annoying
because they can survive in any world in
this situation they put them in accept a
situation where everyone has equal
rights if you live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a closer
side with a minority figure it out we
read smiling and it's effective to damp
magaz everywhere you know magna make
America great again means that they hate
what we have now so they want to go back
to the past but if we go back to the
past we're just gonna get this again
let's kind of the recipe to get this is
what we did in the past
that's like we're like I need this cake
you know what I liked is the time we can
fix it
[Music]
you know black people are people too I
love the Black Panther movie the Black
Panther movie gave black children a hero
they could finally look up to and that's
just someone like one of the King jr.
about the man and Harriet Tubman you're
throwing a marginal or Frederick
Douglass or don't you hit the boy or
nothin
to Michael Jordan Michael Jackson
supervisor Washington Maya Angelou Terry
Robinson Obama Oprah now there's a
favorite that doesn't get confident of
the Kalends cartoon is jack black he's
white
not even black eye
[Music]
Olympic Ahn hours of those cryptic
Chinese protocol Province in China
called South Korea and this Peter Pan
problems my friends like dude hunts
because I like to eat General Tso's
chicken no I do like general so strain
you know that's just a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentically Asian like yeah the song
like my favorite movies rush hour 3
I love being Asian dude everyone's like
oh people you can see dogs which I
understand to be very shocking because
in America gone for two like down the
peppers but in Asia we treat her family
members
members really tradition we have
we're served by an animal we love a
grandma
unless use a baby girl miss case you
throw up derivative really good look at
the reference Tennessee
I love Asian everyone they've Asian
women are beautiful that I want these
Asian men are beautiful which doesn't
even make any sense because how do you
think Asian women are created be [ __ ]
I have a crucial part of the sexy
process please stop trying to scam P if
you have sex with me have children will
be very beautiful
after that nothing happen engineers are
not supportive all right